[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be looking into the early life of
Barty Crouch Jr with a particular focus
on how he became so terribly evil that
is what happened to him during his
childhood in adolescence that may have
contributed to the incredibly dark
wizard he turned out to be in looking
further into his life it seems that his
capacity for doing terrible things came
from a combination of innate evilness
and mental instability here's what I
learned the second of his name Barty was
officially born bartimis Crouch Jr
sometime during the year of 1962 to a
bartimus Crouch senior and a frail wispy
looking wedge known only as Mrs Crouch
growing up Barty Jr was described as a
pale boy with straw-colored hair and
freckles the crouchers came from a long
line of pure blooded witches and wizards
with Barty senior holding a prominent
position in the British Ministry of
magic even back in the 19th 60s as it
were Mr Crouch was extremely focused on
hunting down dark Wizards and held great
Ambitions of one day becoming Minister
for magic so much so that he rarely had
time for his son with this information
it's easy to assume that bharti senior
spent much of his time at the ministry
and very little of it at home with his
family so with that in mind Barty Jr was
by no means abused by his father at
least not physically but as a child he
likely felt quite neglected and it's
easy to see how a young boy may have
believed that a father who appeared to
Value his career above his family loved
his work more than his son still Barty
Jr had his mother's love as it said that
Mrs Crouch loved the boy more than
anything else in the world likely even
Mr Crouch himself at the age of 11 Barty
Jr then attended Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry it is speculated
that based on his age he must have been
there around the same time as other
Wizards that we know of such as Severus
Snape James Potter and the Marauders
upon his arrival at school his widely
rumored that but completely unconfirmed
that bharti Jr was sorted into Ravenclaw
house while this may come as a surprise
to some of you since the majority of
wizards who turned out to be as dark and
evil as Barty Crouch Jr where Southern
students the qualities of a Ravenclaw
quite fit what we know of Barty for
example his approach to infiltrating
Hogwarts to get to Harry on behalf of
Voldemort I.E his impersonation of madai
Moody and his manipulation of the Goblet
of Fire was incredibly creative and
clever two Cornerstone traits of
Ravenclaw House in any case it is said
that Barty Jr took on the dark mark and
became an official Death Eater in his
late teens likely just after graduating
from Hogwarts which solidified his path
towards becoming the sadistic dark
wizard we meet in the Goblet fire in
fact Barty Jr was one of the few Death
Eaters who remained steadfastly loyal to
Voldemort after his fall in October of
1981 and alongside his comrades
including Bellatrix and rodolfus
Lestrange he was one of the Death Eaters
responsible for using the cruciatus
curse on Frank and Alice Longbottom
together they tortured the long bottoms
to the point of insanity in one of the
most infamous crimes of Modern Magic due
to the severity of the crime that is
using an unforgivable curse to the point
of making their victims go insane Barty
Jr and the others were set to be made an
example of the time of their capture
bharti Jr was only 19 years old but was
sentenced to the full extent of the law
by the Council of magical law over which
his own father presided and so despite
barty's senior leading the trial Barty
Jr was sentenced to life imprisonment in
the magical prison of Azkaban condemned
to live out the remainder of his life
amongst the soul-sucking Dementors it is
said that barty's senior who was also
the head of the Department of magical
law enforcement at the time wanted to
make an example of his son due to both
his own disappointments in bharti Jr and
political pressure from the ministry
especially in consideration of the fact
that Marty senior wanted to become
Minister for magic it is rumored that
bati senior was incredibly embarrassed
by his son and the dark path he had
chosen to dedicate his life to and so
thinking that Barty Jr's actions might
undermine his ability to become Minister
some say that the trial was a public
display of humiliation between Father
and Son it's not difficult to see how
this outcome may have furthered bharti
Jr's feelings of neglect and abandonment
by his father pushing him further into
the arms of dark magic however despite
having been sentenced to life
imprisonment by his father bharti Junior
was accused of his Crimes by his mother
without question and so when Mrs Crouch
discovered that she was dying she
convinced her husband who loved her
desperately to help her break out their
son from Azkaban in 1982 with the aid of
his mother Barty Crouch Jr was the first
wizard to escape Azkaban in nearly 300
years both Mrs Crouch and Barty Jr took
polygi's potion to take on the
appearance of one another this allowed
Barty Jr to escape with his father
looking like his mother and leave Mrs
Crouch to die in Azkaban looking like
her son now I can't be sure but it
wouldn't surprise me if the sacrifice of
his wife whom he loved so dearly made
barty's Senior hate his son even more
than ever before despite any ill will
towards his son however he had the
Grouch family house elf winky nurse
party Junior back to health likely in
honor of Mrs Crouch's wishes as Barty Jr
was rather mentally unwell after living
among the Dementors while in Azkaban
whether due to his mental instability or
the fact that he was a True Believer in
the dark lord Barty Jr maintained that
he would one day escape the Crouch
Family Estate
find Voldemort and help him once again
rise to power for this reason bharti
senior kept the younger bati under his
control by way of the imperious curse on
the rare event that bharti senior would
allow his son out in public he kept him
concealed under an invisibility cloak
and so bharti Jr's existence was Kept
Secret but the majority of the Wizarding
World believing he'd died in Azkaban
which of course had actually been his
mother bharti's existence was eventually
uncovered accidentally by Bertha Dawkins
a Ministry of magic employee who came by
the crunch Family Residence to get his
signature from vati senior tragically
for Bertha it was she who
unintentionally revealed Junior survival
and whereabouts to Voldemort an
interrogation which resulted in her
Murder By the dark lord after being kept
under lock and key for over a decade
Barty Jr was basically insane at this
point and I think it's safe to assume
that his mental state was likely the
culmination of his father's neglect
while growing up the fact that he was
put on trial and sentence to life
imprisoned by his own father the time he
spent in Azkaban under the depressing
influence of the Dementors and his
father's mental imprisonment of him
through the imperious curse not to
mention that his only companionship for
more than 10 years would have been that
of Winky well and of course his father
very likely hated him his mental state
aside I do think the party Crouch Jr
still would have pursued being a Death
Eater becoming a rather dark wizard in
the end even if he hadn't gone through
all that since it's clear that even
before he went to Azkaban withstood the
effect of the imperious curse for a
decade he was quite a sadistic person
for example his part in torturing the
long bottoms to the point of insanity
showcases his inclinations towards
violence and innate evilness before he
had truly suffered or undergone much
psychological damage in his final year
of Life Barty Jr was located by
Voldemort in freed and with his freedom
the dark lord tasked him with
infiltrating Hogwarts and capturing
Harry Potter an assignment party took on
with pleasure as we know bharti Jr then
abducted former Aura Alistair Madame
Moody and took on his appearance through
Polyjuice Potion he went on to
impersonate Mad Eye in his role as a
professor at Hogwarts for an entire
school year teaching defense against the
dark arts while also fixing the trial
was a tournament in an effort to bring
Harry face to face with Voldemort Barty
Junior's life was over at the end of
that same school year in 1995. but not
before murdering his father an actor
which may have been almost unavoidable
given their history party Junior's fate
came at the receiving end of a
dementor's kiss performed by dementor
the administer for magic Cornelius fudge
had brought with him to Hogwarts and
with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think do you
agree that bharti crunch Jr was already
pretty evil to begin with or do you
think his experiences played a larger
role please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the Channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live